reason why we make that comment is that
her leadership has been undermined by
this result quite clearly she went from
having a very strong lead and an
expectation of possibly a triple digit
increase in seats for conservatives and
in Parliament to a worse result a hung
parliament and given that the election
was positioned as a referendum on on her
vote for me and my team Theresa May that
plus the the sense of a lack of a
majority for so-called hard brexit has
really undermined her leadership though
clearly the Conservative Party's best
hope is that she stays on yes you're
saying new elections expected within 12
months listen I what we've seen with the
the rental towers developments for
example and the subsequent controversy
over the state of fire protection is
that events unexpected events can also
happen to impact perceived political
competence legitimacy and everything
else and these are unfor
a misstep on brexit or reaction to
another unexpected event I think will
will fatally wound her her leadership in
this respect say there's a conservative
leadership contest followed by another
general election all of that eats into
the negotiating time that the UK with EU
I think the only actors that really
wants new elections are the Labour Party
given Corbin strong performance but I'm
not advocating for this outcome so much
as I think that the UK has entered a
period of real political volatility
where the search for legitimacy and this
addressing this question of what the
British people have asked for is now
really more open one of the potential
bumps in the road that you're predicting
is the conversation that we're going to
have imminently on the exit bill yeah
100 million euros potentially that's
going to be really damaging for the
government you think because the UK
surrendered in terms of the sequencing
of dis
Russians well I mean I think it was
inevitable that I wouldn't call it
surrender it was it was the mandate from
from from the European Union and here's
another point you know the UK doesn't
have the the leverage that I think it
taught it did going into these
negotiations particularly as the
continent looks stronger politically
following microns win so so that's the
first thing I think is headline risk of
this big number so what that much of
this these costs are already factored
into the budget and it's you know
services and and payments that the UK is
required to make anyway I think for the
man on the street this looks you know
potentially ridiculous and unfair and so
I'm suggesting that the size of that
bill might cause additional political
blowback this is potentially the most
explosive comment in your notes of all
you say we cannot rule out the
possibility that the UK may not leave
the EU at all you really think that's
going to happen I don't think it's
explosive at all I think it's a purely
an extrapolation of the the sheer scale
of what has to be done and how long it
will take and my experience as a
political scientist and someone who's
been doing political analysis for
financial markets for more than twenty
years now but I date myself is that the
longer it takes before something to
happen something happens the less chance
there is that it actually happens and so
a possible kind of limbo a long-standing
interim period grace period whatever
we're calling a transition period might
extend long enough that we hit a new
political cycle and then we might find
that public opinion is in a different
place and so that's the the underpinning
for my argument you spend a fair bit of
time on the road recently talking about
this report with with clients what are
the kind of questions that they're
asking you well I think that outside of
the UK there's great lack of
understanding about what's happening a
you know a request for a sort of
decision tree about how all of us may
work because as we know ourselves here
being in the country and reading the
papers every day and in some of us you
know knowing
about the technicalities it's incredibly
complex it's very bureaucratic they want
to know about timelines they want to
know about the possibility of so-called
reversal which again I emphasize but
only I think happened with either a new
election fought explicitly on that
mandate or a vote on a package but
there's confusion and and that again is
not something that investors tend to
appreciate